hey youtubers is charlie so I had a
chance to see early footage from hitman
agent 47 the new movie that they're
making so this is going to be a
breakdown of the movie just in case
you're not familiar with the lore and
just a top 5 reasons to get hype so
starting with number 5 back to the
source so when they were making the
movie they wanted to do a completely new
virgin so they dug way deeper into the
Lord of the game series so if you're a
big fan of the games you're gonna have a
lot of fun but you don't have to
understand the game to understand the
movie that that's really what I'm here
for rupert friend is playing agent 47
you probably know him from homeland if
you if you haven't seen him on that you
need to he was like the best thing about
last season I don't want to spoil any of
that but he plays a blackops CIA
operative on the show so anytime things
get crazy he's like the guy that shuts
it down hardcore BAM his hit man
character is obviously totally different
from his homeland character but they're
both really strong anti-hero's so i
always get really excited it's like
rooting for magneto in an x-man film so
that actually leads it to number for the
new cast most of the talk most of the
stuff that we've learned about the movie
so far has actually been from Zachary
Quinto who's playing John Smith he's
from the video game series and Hannah
ware who's playing Katia van Dee's
they're both characters that flow from
the video game but Zachary Quintos
character actually did appear in the
video game series if you're familiar
with the Carlton Smith character he's
the CIA operative he's a minor character
in the franchise the movie turned him
into like a much more heightened badass
version of that I feel like Zachary
Quinto is perfect for really angry
action just those crazy scary eyebrows
that he has the movie revolves around
those those three characters though
agent 47 John Smith and Katya you really
don't have to play the game to
understand the characters back stories
but it is always fun to look at the
video game stuff if you want like extra
recommended reading moving on to number
three the lure of hitman so the lord of
the universe is really cool so just
explain a little bit agent 47s the
result of decades of genetic research to
create the perfect killer his DNA flows
from each of what is called the five
fathers five criminal masterminds that
were part of the same french military
unit in the 1950s they all became
friends and one of them dr. Otto
Wolfgang ort Meyer pitched the idea to
create an army of super human clones
sounds perfect what could go wrong so
each of them gave the doctor their DNA
and as they each rose to power as crime
lords they gave him dump trucks of money
to finish his research so after decades
and grew
sink groups of clones agent 47 was
produced ciarán hinds is listed on the
IMDb page is playing a character named
scientist so I I don't think you would
cast Mance Rayder in a film if he wasn't
going to be critical to the plot so I
think he's going to be part of the lore
of the founding fathers in the video
game they're all really old but they
harvest organs from clones to keep
themselves young remember they're trying
to create an army of genetic clone so
they have a lot of spares lying around
in the context of the series they're all
approaching like 100 years old but they
all look like they're in their 50s and
60s you also might recognize Thomas
Kretschmann AK Baron von Strucker he's
playing a character named Alice circ as
you'd imagine they don't they don't
really cast notable villain character
actors these are going to be like really
minor roles so also expect him to tie in
with the lord of the five fathers to
kretschmann is one of those characters
that i was getting really excited about
when I see him pop up in genre films
number two badass Hannah where you might
remember her from that Kelsey Grammer
series boss but she was also an old boy
and she was in the Michael Fassbender
movie shame so the game series is all
about the one character agent 47 it
follows his story is far back as Comic
Con last year Hannah was talking about
some of the really awkward funny moments
that her character had in the context of
the action the fight scenes so as much
as the movie follows the Hitman
character in his perspective we also get
to see a lot from her perspective she's
the point of entry into the world of
agent 47 the five fathers watching her
kick ass in the film is gonna be one of
the most fun things ever it'll be fun to
see agent 47 try to deal with her he is
very moral character so I'm really
interested to see the movie explore that
on the surface he just seems like that
stone cold killer but all the other
characters start to unravel his humanity
and this really awesome Frankenstein's
monster way really the the number one
reason to get hype is all the crazy gun
kada and matrix level stunts the story
itself just lends itself to the that
lyrical visual storytelling you see in
extremely choreographed fight movies
like Hong Kong action John Woo style
married to the modern action set piece I
really feel like we have the golden age
of television to thank for that like
cinematic television is really pushing
the boundaries of what film is doing now
the two big filming locations where
Germany and Singapore so that's where
most of the big action set pieces are
going to take place as you'd expect you
know the architecture the culture and
formed the types of fight scenes that
you see in each place they were in
Germany for about the first two thirds
of the movie and then they went to
Singapore
for the last part i actually heard the
claim the asian 47 is the first major
blockbuster from Hollywood to shoot in
Singapore the footage in the trailer is
going to spell it all out give you guys
a much better look at all the crazy
action okay everybody hitman agent 47
I'm going to be showing the leaked
footage it's going to be really awesome